los seres humanos siempre nos hemos dado
cuenta que existen algunas cosas que son
más largas que otras por ejemplo si
tengo estos dos segmentos entonces se ve
que este segmento de acá es más largo
que el de arriba pero a veces no es
suficiente saber que una cosa es más
larga que otra sino que queremos saber
qué tan más larga es y para eso lo que
tenemos que hacer es medir entonces
necesitamos determinar alguna forma para
medir estos segmentos y la forma en la
cual hacemos eso es tomar nosotros
segmento al cual le llamamos un segmento
unitario y decimos que este segmento
tiene longitud una unidad una unidad
unidad teniendo este segmento como
referencia pues podemos ver que tanta
longitud tienen estos segmentos viendo
cuántas veces cabe este segmento unidad
en ellos entonces por ejemplo aquí
arriba cabe al parecer dos veces por lo
tanto decimos que la longitud de este
segmento es de dos unidades
unidades unidades y de manera similar en
el segmento de abajo cabe pues como tres
veces vale entonces decimos que la
longitud de este segmento es de tres
unidades unidades vale unidades y bueno
en realidad no utilizamos unidades
abstractas casi siempre utilizamos
unidades como centímetros o como
pulgadas o pies por ejemplo más o menos
algo de este estilo sería un centímetro
bueno depende claro de del tamaño de
pantalla que tengas pero si esto de aquí
es un centímetro entonces esto de acá
más o menos sería como una pulgada y
bueno un pie sería mucho más largo y un
metro pues todavía más largo va entonces
aquí tendríamos centímetros por acá
tendríamos pulgadas y pues son varias
formas de medir la longitud vale bueno
este de aquí es el caso en una dimensión
le voy a poner aquí arriba una dimensión
y decimos que estamos en una dimensión
porque los objetos únicamente se pueden
medir en un sentido nada más tienen una
longitud bueno pues vamos a pensar qué
sucede ahora en dos dimensiones
dos dimensiones aquí en dos dimensiones
ahora los objetos tienen un alto y una y
un ancho o puedes pensar los como un
largo y un alto vaya ahora tienen dos
cosas que se tienen que medir entonces
los objetos serían pues podría ser por
ejemplo cuadrados no esté cuadrado de
acá y este cuadrado de acá y el espacio
que ocupan ahora se llama área observa
que ahora es el espacio que ocupan pero
en dos dimensiones por ejemplo en una
pantalla o en un papel y bueno
claramente otra vez este segundo
cuadrado tiene más área que este primero
pero de nuevo sería bueno poder medir
qué tanta más área tiene con respecto a
este de acá y para eso sería bueno saber
cómo medimos el área bueno pues para
hacer eso ahora lo que hacemos es
definir un cuadrado unitario un cuadrado
unitario y este cuadrado unitario lo que
cumple es que cada uno de sus lados
tiene longitud una unidad
unidad y acá también una unidad unidad
vale y al área que cubre este cuadrado
le llamamos una unidad cuadrada una
unidad unidad cuadrada se pone aquí
arriba vale si estamos trabajando con
unidades de centímetros entonces sería
un centímetro cuadrado si son pulgadas
serían pulgadas cuadradas y así
sucesivamente vale bueno ya teniendo
este cuadradito unitario para medir el
área de estos cuadrados podemos
preguntarnos cuántos de estos
cuadraditos unitarios caben en este en
estos cuadrados de acá y para eso pues
déjame dividirlos pensemos que la
longitud de aquí es de dos unidades y de
aquí es de tres unidades entonces este
primer cuadrado se puede dividir en
cuatro cuadraditos unitarios de esta
forma de esta forma y por lo tanto
decimos que su área es cuatro unidades
cuadradas
con unidades cuadradas y de manera
similar este lo podemos dividir en 9 más
o menos así como algo de este estilo
vale en 9 cuadraditos unitarios
entonces serían uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis siete ocho nueve y por lo
tanto decimos que su área es nueve
unidades unidades cuadradas vale ok
entonces ya tenemos longitud y área en
una dimensión y dos dimensiones pero
nosotros vivimos en un mundo pues con al
menos tres dimensiones si tenemos
tenemos forma de movernos con un alto
con un ancho y con una profundidad
entonces ahora vamos al caso de tres
dimensiones que es como el de la vida
real tres dimensiones va ahora los
objetos como te comento tienen un largo
un alto y una profundidad entonces se
verían más o menos algo de este estilo
déjame pintar por aquí un cúbito
este de aquí es un cubo vamos a pensar
que es un cubo donde cada uno de sus
lados tiene tiene longitud tiene
longitud 2 vale y vamos a pensar que por
acá hay otro cubo un poco más grande
donde ahora cada uno de sus lados tiene
longitud 3 más o menos algo de este
estilo
bueno pues ahora queremos preguntarnos
qué tanto espacio ocupan estos cubos
aquí en tres dimensiones a ese espacio
que ocupan se le llama volumen recuerda
en tres dimensiones se le llama volumen
en dos dimensiones es área o sea el área
es que tanto espacio dos dimensional
ocupamos y la longitud es que tanto
espacio uno dimensional ocupamos pero
bueno regresemos aquí al volumen que es
y qué tanto espacio se ocupa así en tres
dimensiones lo puedes pensar como en la
vida real vale bueno otra vez para saber
cuánto espacio ocupan cada uno de éstos
lo que hacemos es definir un cúbito
unitario donde cada uno de los lados
tiene longitud 1
entonces ahí tenemos un cubito más o
menos algo de este estilo y ahora lo que
tenemos es que su largo su alto y su
profundidad son de una unidad una unidad
con una unidad
y una unidad una unidad vale y a este
espacio que que cubre un cubito de estos
le llamamos una unidad
unidad cúbica bueno entonces otra vez
tenemos que ver cuántos cubitos de éstos
caben acá pero ahora no va a estar tan
fácil verlo porque algunos cubitos
quedan escondidos si no se ha dividido
este cubo de acá en cubitos unitarios me
quedaría algo de este estilo pero para
realmente entender qué está pasando lo
que voy a tener que hacer es separar las
dos capas hay una rebanada abajo y una
rebanada arriba y cada una de las
rebanadas se ve más o menos así haré
algo de este estilo algo de este estilo
está quedando un poquito chueca ahí está
ya quedó más bonita entonces cada una de
las rebanadas se ve así y cada una de
las rebanadas tiene cuatro cubitos
unitarios como son dos rebanadas
entonces en total tiene 8 cubitos
unitarios y por lo tanto decimos que el
volumen de este cubo es 8 unidades
unidades cúbicas y de manera similar
este de acá también lo podemos dividir
en cubitos unitarios ahora va a quedar
usted un poco más difícil de hacer
verdad porque son muchos cubitos como
que va creciendo bastante el espacio
conforme aumentamos las dimensiones pero
bueno déjame acabar de dividir entonces
ahora tendríamos algo más o menos de
este estilo más o menos de este estilo
vale y ahora no tendríamos dos rebanadas
sino tres rebanadas esta de acá estaría
acá y esta de acá y cada una de las
rebanadas se vería más o menos hasta el
árbol este estilo sería una rebanada y
cada una de las rebanadas tiene tres
cubitos unitarios en cada lado algo así
y finalmente algo así vale y observemos
que cada rebanada tiene 123456789
cubitos como son tres rebanadas este
cubo tiene en total este tres por nueve
cubitos unitarios es decir tiene 27
cubitos unitarios y por lo tanto asume
su volumen es de 27 unidades unidades
cúbicas muy bien espero que este vídeo
te haya gustado y que nos ayude a darnos
cuenta cómo medimos las cosas
especialmente que nos ayude a entender
cómo medimos cuánto espacio ocupa un
objeto en tres dimensiones y bueno
también que quede claro esta idea de que
a ese espacio se le conoce como volumen